welcome to this video this is the
highlights video for the 12th rounds of
the candidates tournament and countyman
disk and here we're nearing the end of
the tournament and honored of course
leading the event the other guys need to
catch up if they want to post some sort
of a threat the last couple of rounds
let's look at the games one by one and
start with them with the pursuers from
Holland Aronian crumbly crumbly cos
basically out of it already is on - one
score has basically no chance to catch
on and he's trailing by two points this
is too much and the Ronin is a plus one
he has got still a little bit of Hope
left but he would need to get in a win
somewhere and this is probably a chance
with white so let's see what happens we
got a Queens gambit declined
surprisingly enough in the purest form
that would fashioned form which allows
the exchange variation generally
considered to be a slightly more
comfortable for white
we said this normal moves on the board
see this in the bud now aronia plays the
slightly odd move 83 yttrium a normal
idea in the exchange but it's nobody
played as some would later we however
transposed to a known structure black
wins for this night h5 idea to exchange
some pieces and now sets up and form
queenside castling both sides Castle
queenside and destruction yeah
white generally wants to play on the
Queen side try to like here get a knight
to c5 well Black has this very solid
setup here the knight on d6 is
especially well placed covering all
kinds of critical squares black in the
right moment wants to exchange the
bishop this could be supported by g6
and long-term might do something on the
kingside however after 95 g6 attending
possibly this move aronia played the
interesting idea h4 tried to attack with
h5 this is actually directed at the
center as white likes to put a knight on
e5 without being arrests by a possible
f6 this is an important thing
if black male would do nothing just to
show the point okay I understand that
this doesn't make much sense to move the
King then white would get the Knight to
e5 and with H pawns gone there is never
the idea even to play of six as g6
is dropping this is an idea of this h5
push to soften up them the King side but
kramnik defended well in this case he
played first bishop back and then g5
looks a bit strange at first and you're
dropping the pawn yes you are but he had
seen that this is another problem
Aronian took it and after G form they
turned out that white has a hard time to
move the knight anywhere else than h4
it's not very well placed on the square
like that Queen f6 is in fact quite an
annoying move white must be cautious you
cannot even do that as this drops the
Queen nice little line yeah he decided
to put it on h4 Queen f6
and g3 just putting it or just stab
let's say setting up a solid structure
on the King side
Knight to c4 and now he dropped the
bishop back it's you cannot keep it
there forever black was intending to get
the phone back anyway and this was it
was not able to - white wasn't able to
prevent that yeah black he got it back
rook e1 yeah the only idea left really
is reform
and here we go efore played now a
chronic played the movie six attacking
this this forepaws this outpost night on
c5 and it seems that he Aronian really
committed a serious mistake but we'll
see that it was not punished he now
played Knight a four and this low should
land white into big trouble he must he
really must play idiot xt5 which still
seems to be quite okay here black can
try with 95 to win apiece but wide
retains very serious conversation for
that as especially before would attack
this knight on the side it's been tricky
to show he and in the short version of
the of the game the the real problem is
that Aronian in didn't take he played
the just Knight a form and now I'm going
to show you what was played in the game
they played Bishop a 695 back pretty bad
695 and Bishop c8 and great game drawn
ok the problem is however that all those
times after we were here Knight a 4
Kramnik has the possibility to not play
Bishop a6 but to play Knight b5 and this
really needs to very very substantial
trouble for what it's simply this pawn
is a text and it's a huge hits a huge
fork on the forum I believe that white
is almost almost losing him I don't
don't really see a defense at least you
get to very very uncomfortable positions
I mean the best is probably something
like this takes Knight a5 an important
point Queen back and then rook t5 which
is very important that this h5 rookies
suddenly getting back into the game and
here white is just losing deform you can
try to defend like
for example but black is just
substantially better it's it's a pawn
and it's activity note that this night
is terribly placed so 95 I believe would
have won the game for chrome wickets I
don't know I don't see anything with a
computer I mean also does not it's a
it's quite quite funny how how bad
White's position suddenly is with this
porno dropping yeah I don't know he
probably saw the draw and this is such
such a horror tournament for Kramnik
that he probably was glad to to just
have the draw and and have the game
finished so maybe it didn't even look
for for something else it would have
been interesting though to to see if
Aaron ever found the defense okay our
next game to palos Whitlam here the
rules are pretty clear to Paulo is is on
-2 and last in the tournament he cannot
qualify anymore
well it's villas on 50% and he still has
the last round game against on and so
with the win somewhere he would have
really a chance really and easy to see
chance win the game win against Vichy
and qualified not easy but at least
something that seems half way possible
ok he played black against to pawn off
and we had a 10-month of Sicilian b5 is
an somewhat Woodroof but pretty decent
one that has been forgotten so for a
while
96 is the maintenance here for white
announced with La Plata moves D takes c6
which I found really surprising to be
honest this is a very unusual recapture
normally black plays Queen c6 and tries
to get typical play on the C file which
is still open and on the long diagonal
after the point we capture however after
a form he felt yeah he felt he needed to
play even before
he probably there was some some tricks
vailable with taking and even porn night
sex 'i'm so if one was played a before
was played night be one and now we see
that white is always getting a night to
see for which is just very nice and this
position is just a strategic yeah i
would call it a nightmare almost it's
not it's not like losing but it's a it's
so one so unattractive this bishop is
always biting on granite the night has
nowhere to go no 95 while white has this
eternal peace on c-- form and simply the
better structure we see that here black
even was forced to play e5 even
weakening d5 and this is cisu and just
so uncomfortable the pile of just played
all the normal positional moves and got
this very nice position after the
capture here on before however his villa
absolutely was forced to take with the
apron he took with the c-pawn we take
with the apron
you have this idea and you don't
immediately lose material after this
caption ever there was Bishop e6 young
and yeah after the first capture here
it is almost impossible for black to not
lose a 5 in the upcoming moves we see
that white was invading on the fifth
rank even and at the end got the e5 pawn
and well only a couple of moves later
Smith levels Chang was forced to resign
as Queen d5 is going to decide the game
ultimately Queen trade will simply
promote the apron so yeah to be honest
somewhat of a strange game s doing
rather yeah rather deliberately for this
in my book completely awful structures
is just very strange I don't I don't
really get it to be honest it's it's
totally unattractive you can never ever
win the game with black words in this in
this type of bond formation and you're
just worse the whole time it's just a
matter how how worse are you are you
much worse I you just slightly worse and
suffering it's a it's tough tough to
tell I mean Quincy six on the other hand
is a perfectly normal Sicilian middle
game one one issue of this line is that
black is somewhat trailing in
development but it is not really easy
for Y to make anything out of that I had
played this line myself sometimes in the
1990s and didn't really have much
problems back then with the Queen Queen
capture I had looked at this move I know
this had looked at this because I
thought maybe black manages something to
play e5 Bishop e6 but you're never going
you're never coming that far even after
a four you get attacked on the Queen
side so quickly okay um next game by the
way this also means that Svidler out of
it with now also beam back on - call
Mahmud young of Coyoacan let's look at
this game both won 50 percent and need a
win to get some kind of hope or have
some hope left
mummy-ji office again playing the f3
line this sharp line that he used to
beat Aronian with and kayaking is
playing this very sharp counter counter
gambit so to say counter again but yet
it's not a counter gambit it's let's say
yeah it's a it's initiating i'ma counter
play typical father for the Blumenthal
and other gambit lines and tell me why
does getting this the center but black
is trying to destroy it
and this actually worked I would rather
nice for black at first
he managed to to break through here in
the center and win one of the ponds and
second one which yeah well it's it's one
one extra powerful back but on the other
hand White has the Queen aggressively
placed near the king and white will have
regrouping ideas to get more pieces on
the king and after a couple of moves we
see that this actually actually
materialized I believe actually that
night D to c5 what kayaking plenteous
maybe maybe not the best defense it
seems that a5 has maybe a bit bit better
as you in this position you can actually
use the d7 and also for defensive
purposes okay but this was played and we
see that now white is really going for
it here g6 must be played h6 is
immediately immediately over so g6 and
now after 95 and this trade we see that
the dark squares are seriously weak and
white is getting a very very dangerous
attack now kayaking took on c3 not just
grabbing another pawn but also intending
to take on e5 to get rid of this this
the some attacking unit only five it's
not just the pawn it's also supporting
the attack yeah rook I have to plate
giving away or not sorry protecting c2
and G 294 Bishop h6 and Knight back to
c6 yeah black had various ideas here to
defend he could to go to c6 and take a 5
or go 96 which also seems to be okay in
general I think that white the tech is
dangerous but it shouldn't lead to a
direct mate black seems to be okay
positioned in terms of defense knight c6
plate and lucrative one twin takes d5
this was blacks idea getting the e5 pawn
note that white can always take on f8 in
in those lines here but it simply gives
up this important
taking peace and does not have white at
all you need to have this peace to
attack the bishop 186 look at five no my
mom you are off really shocking move but
quite a strong one
if black now takes this route d5 another
sacrifice and this forces the draw
actually blush and always show also draw
with those checks what can also not play
for windows rook t1 Queenie five and
then Robert e5 even as a non sacrifice
just putting it on d5 it will force the
drum so this was a funny way to end the
game but kayaking played for win with
Queenie 7 which was very risky after
Bishop g5 played f6 yeah it just needed
serve this was so needed this means
details in the long video it's a super
complicated game and Normandie are off
took on d5 with this rook
it seems that Bishop takes f6 would have
led to a very very dangerous attack with
Kyle Atkins a huge time travel I have my
doubts that he would have been able to
defend this position it might even be
objectively good for white but I
couldn't firmly establish that with a
limited time the position is just just
too complicated
Mahmud geographer decided to take on d5
and now on c4 his two pawns down but
still has caught attacking chances after
Queen e6 Bishop e3 adhere rook to e8
quite funny with this counter threat the
mate only one if white plays something
like that he's connect it's getting
planted here this is also a member tiara
pushed edge for securing against the
mate and at the same time intending to
to capture at some point yeah here
probably kayaking should have taken but
it's it's probably also leading to a
draw but it's it's more testing he plant
23 after which we got an endgame
with black I'm having an extra pawn but
it's not enough to win white has active
rooks and this bishop is also a strong
piece in fact he even exchanged it after
a couple of moves but the double Luke
endgame here is just a draw because
white is so active always attacking the
pawn on e5 black has no way forward
after a couple of moves
check check check check check
yeah someone Artyom they hear they agree
to a draw yeah a big fight and this kind
of format where you need to go quickly
through a game is really not doing it
any justice it was very complicated and
if you enjoy some technical technical
fights you can go to the long video
where I'm showing a bit of a bit more of
that also funny to analyze it yourself
if you like okay so what is the
situation or the result of those three
games the results were really good for
Anand to be honest
T'Pol of winning against food Allah is
great so sweet Allah is out of the
picture and the other guys are just
drawing and not catching up so let's see
what Anand did he had white against
Dmitri Andre Kim then dragon played the
cow corn this is a line that he
sometimes plays we get to the classical
system of the camel car I'm doing this
really quickly because the middle game
is just too complicated Queen f3 this is
an improvement by Hana on his World
Championship match game against scars
where he played 94 which after all those
traits was pretty much pretty much equal
Queen f3 is the more interesting move
getting out of the default and intending
to attack on descent and on the King
side it was up to this point quite a
logical game I believe black na played
a3 b3 Bishop before
III and in this position it seems that
under aching is committing a mistake he
played but a very yeah with hindsight
you it's easier
he played c5 which is of course pretty
normal move you need to attack the
center at some point it just seems to be
a bit miss time TM a nun can push no d5
which he did it takes takes he in fact
he had a interesting at alternative and
Knight f5 which is somewhat of a
computer move maybe but it's interesting
to look at and it seems to be quite
quite good for white details in the in
the long video but he just recaptured
for just the human move of course Knight
b6 and nighty to d3 to support the d5
pawn here is another critical position
of the game white obviously has the idea
to play Knight to a5 which kayaking
come on and Dracon sorry prevented with
Quincy aid we are covering covering a5
which nevertheless proved to be a
mistake this Queen c8 move it seems that
he needed to take on d5 probably not a
move that you love to make giving up the
two knights IAM but this was probably
what black needed to do something like
that seems to put out seems to give
black enough claim it's not great but
probably you need to do that he played
this and now d6 was why it's answer and
black now is in big big trouble the pawn
is always threatening to push through
and white has various attacking ideas
connected with Knight h5 for example
which gets rid of this defensive night
and there's Luke g3 and well it's a big
attack play drew p8 and now Knight h5
plate broken six now and here we come to
the opposition where now are not could
have
decided to game immediately with with
some precise calculation he had the
choice between basically two wins and he
chose the here he chose the more
complicated one actually the longer one
d7 here would have won the game with the
main point being that after a move like
Queen c7 there is the strong reply d5
rook takes takes gf Bishop h6 and this
is the decisive attack with this mating
threat the Queen takes is also possible
but after Mookie three-wide wins easily
the Queen retreats I'm taking here and
I'm just breaking through very easily
this happening was a pretty clear-cut
win but he played Knight takes f6 it's
still winning but it's not it's not so
decisive in comparison d7 Queen c7 and q
g4 this was Alan's idea rook g3 coming
and it also leads to two winning
position but it's not so clear cut as
mentioned c4 Luke 3 3 3 6 and now h6
yeah white is threatening to take on g6
and this will also be a decisive attack
but it's not so easy let's look takes on
b3 yeah black is threatening this
intermediate check rook takes and Knight
a phone rings trying everything to get
some sort of counter play against
White's King which is a bit a bit out in
the open
takes now here and now on and took the
bishop yeah it's a piece right
check winces died c3 check King C - and
now b5 this is a very good defensive
move something like this is just too
easy
with white having very good coordination
and let's not even having a serious
check Ian Queen d5 is coming b5 is the
much much stronger stronger move King b3
going out of out of the the discovered
check and now night a form in this
position unemployed to move Queen to f3
it turns out with with the above the
computer you can establish that here
Bishop d2 was the stronger move but it's
um it's really a really am not like it
was all very very self evident Queen f3
looks a completely logical to me
especially with a little time
it covers c3 it gets the Queen back into
into the action in the center Queen to
d5 as a move and then and it's also a
winning move it's not like it it's a big
mistake Bishop t2 was just a bit a bit
simpler Jack got to check Queen working
back to see to check check again and now
analyst repeating because he wants this
exact position to happen after move 40
so that he now has time again to figure
out what exactly to do now yeah and he
had a very very defined choice he can
pick King b3 and claim the draw by
threefold repetition or he can play on
with with the move and it turned out
after about 15 minutes thought he
decided to play King b3 to take the draw
which is a slight disappointment as it
was such a great game and he could have
won he could have won I'm telling with
telling you that right away but it was
not a simple win not a simple win at all
um my tesam has probably two ways to do
it we can go to d2 which after something
like that
leads to a position where black still
has some practical counter chances and
this is I believe what Anand also had
seen that this is not totally easy
I mean White's position is not very well
coordinated and black still has lots of
material left to attack it's I'm pretty
sure in another tournament situation
white would've wished she would have
taken this position to play and it also
turns out that if you analyze it with
the help of a computer it turns it turns
up a really funny line
oopsie form and this is the most
decisive of all to be to be honest black
needs to take and now white has two ways
to to win this Bishop a3 is a more human
way to do it intending Bishop to e7 it's
not that easy a Queen b6 black can do
things and he also has the move Knight G
form which is winning it in a totally
spectacular fashion after this but I
refer you to the to the longer long and
then does this because the lines there's
so many fun lines here that you really
should look at this so we draw a draw at
the end and this means that there's so
little suspense left in the event if
Anand would have won it it would have
been over almost but so it's not it's
not completely decided I will pull up
the tournament table quickly so that's
that suspending standings just two games
left which basically means that
mathematically speaking the guys on - -
with your I mean our points are
completely out of it they cannot
overtake on and they all have the worst
try brackets it's useless and the only
one the only really dangerous players
left or the most dangerous player let's
select is actually kayaking because he
plays are not in the
round if he would beat him this is the
only scenario that is in some way
interesting if he would beat Ireland
kayaking would come close was just half
a point trailing him and having the
better tie break as he had won against
Arnhem if then Vichy only draws against
window friends in the kayaking wins yet
another game then he would actually tie
the score and overtake him
it all comes to what we she is doing in
the next two rounds if he plays two
draws he will Eva qualify very clearly
I'm not very clearly it's just it's just
like that if he plays two draws he's
through because he's got the better tie
break against Tyrone young um yeah
Antone it just is just about the game
against Kuryakin he's got black though
kurakin will certainly try everything to
to win this would be interesting to see
him moving interesting to see what kind
of opening they will be playing only
known I would say that Allan's chances
to qualify our let's say between 80 and
90% I would I would say well if he would
have won this game against and wrecking
and I would I would it would be probably
on 99% in this case he would have yeah I
would only two losses I could could
really do the trick in the last round
Arnold is playing with white against
Whitlam who does not have any any
ambition at all left and in this I don't
see him losing this game with white but
I don't know if he would lose against
kayaking this is a an entirely new
dimension but the island has played so
so were consistent in this event I I
don't I don't really see it happening
but of course this was all the last
really really interesting point this
will be the last real interesting point
in
this event so let's let's hope we get a
good game on on Saturday tomorrow Friday
is a rest day so it will continue on
march 13th 29th actually I'm sorry
this Saturday alright thanks for
watching this has been a bit longer
that's video but just too much to cover
thanks for watching